Speaker 1: Let's go to Anibal from Guatemala.
Welcome to the program.
Speaker 5: Hi.
How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 5: Okay.
Okay.
I have a little question.
How did you deal with negation?
I am talking about well, in Guatemala, we
had a really big war, a field wire some years
ago.
And even today, I have some colleague features
who are talking about how the glorious army
of Guatemala who committed genocide was too
good for us.
They keep us away from the communists and
thanks to God and all of of our.
Okay, now we are not.
Venezuela is really.
Speaker 1: You're saying they just deny basic
reality?
Speaker 5: Yep.
And even if I say, well, maybe it's not the
dog, you can see a lot of religious groups
have looked for the evidence of this.
And every time they say something like, oh,
but you know, they were just colleagues or
Jews are sorry, or the Syrian, the English
sweet, the Jesuits.
Yes, yes.
Or everything is the fault of the Masons Illuminati.
Speaker 2: But yeah.
Speaker 5: It's really bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't when people are just
straight up, you know, they don't live in
reality.
It's very difficult.
You know, there is an example from Argentina
as well where of course there was as many
people know, there was this Falklands War
that took place, Isla Malvinas, as they're
known in Argentina.
And the other day, you know, the.
I don't want to pretend that there is literally
only one interpretation of every detail, but
I think it's hard to it's hard to deny that
that was a completely idiotic, wrong headed
move in Argentina to distract from the horrors
of the military dictatorship.
And it was just an absurd thing for Argentina
to be doing.
And the other day when it was like the anniversary,
I saw a news piece that basically like they'd
just brought in a few veterans who fought
for Argentina in that conflict, and they acted
like it was, you know, World War Two fighting
against the Nazis as opposed to a completely
contrived and wrongheaded propaganda conflict.
And it's like if if that's the alternate reality
you're living in, I don't know that we can
even really talk, you know?
I mean, it's just so disconnected from the
truth.
Speaker 5: Yes, I know.
Let me recommend you a really great movie
like your own now from Hyrule Bustamante.
Not the one about the aquarium brought out
of a lab like Your Honor.
Speaker 1: Okay, I will.
Speaker 5: Check it out.
Four lutely amazing.
He even went to the show.
Live show relief of the Oscars.
Well, how about that?
DBM all president Alejandro Giammattei is
talking about how how Jewish Abe is making
claims and helping people to carry Abe agenda
for impeachment.
And it all feels so wrong.
I mean, a saltier, like a poor Republican
idea in Guatemala.
And they are talking about how this group
of indigenous people who committed a human
sacrifice are now going to go bananas.
Nobody body famed juju just like ease of use
a whole every touch foundation is talking
with Alejandro Giammattei.
Everything is so obvious.
Then there are those making the claim about
critical race theory.
But in Guatemala.
Speaker 1: Interesting.
I don't know enough about that, but it sounds
interesting and I will research it.
Speaker 5: I'm pretty sure there are just
Republicans who are helping Alejandro Giammattei
because they want to use this area of critical
race theory everywhere, right?
Yeah.
Speaker 1: When all you have is a hammer,
everything.
Everything looks like a nail.
Listen, Anibal, I do have to let you go, but
quick question.
What?
I know nothing about the cuisine of your country.
What is a what is a typical food item in Guatemala?
Speaker 5: There are a lot of soup through
some of the greatest things and maybe Karthik
either means syntactical red soup.
It is amazing.
Is made of chili is beef or maybe chicken.
It's amazing.
Speaker 1: All right.
Very good.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
All right.
There is Anibal from Guatemala.
Let's go next.
Where are we going next?
Let's go to Logan from San Jose, California.
Logan, welcome.
Speaker 2: Baby.
Jane, can you hear me all right?
Speaker 1: Sort of, yeah.
There's something weird going on, but I think
we can.
We can make it work.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Oh, God.
Question and answer.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to have to let you
go.
It's it's not workable.
The audio just went it went very, very bad,
completely nuclear and horrifying.
Let's go to Shelley from Indiana.
Shelley, welcome.
Speaker 2: David, my question today was about
the student loan forgiveness.
Okay.
So with all of that, with all of the people
that are against it, it seems like they kind
of encourage the lawsuits against it.
I mean, would there be a lawsuit against it
right now?
My question is, at what point do these lawsuits
that they're encouraging end up costing more
money than it would have to actually supported
the program?
Speaker 1: I don't know the answer to that.
I mean, I think the lawsuits.
The lawsuits would have to go on for a really
long time and be multi-jurisdictional and
be very expensive before they would approximate
the cost of the student debt relief.
But I don't even know that that's necessarily
the best argument to make for why this doesn't
make any sense.
Remember, the student loan debt forgiveness
would be economically stimulative.
It would free up money rather than being paid
for interest on loans to be injected into
the economy and to businesses of all sorts
of different kinds.
So you're not making your argument is fine,
which is the lawsuits to fight the forgiveness
cost money.
And at some point that's going to add up to
a whole bunch of money.
It's also that the student loan debt forgiveness
would be very good demand side stimulus and
good for the economy.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah, you're right.
I agree.
I guess the other question is, then what what
do they actually do with the interest that
they're already getting from all of these
loans?
And what is it like for all of the years of
of the interest that they've already done?
What is that ultimately paid for?
Speaker 1: I'm not sure.
I understand.
You're saying what should happen in the context
of the forgiveness with already paid interest.
Speaker 2: Well, I'm saying like where when
they do collect the interest because I'm in
pain on my school loans for 20 years.
Right.
So you're figuring, you know, oh.
Speaker 1: It's it's profits or it goes back
if they're government loans, then it goes
back into the government coffers.
I mean, it's just like any debt service.
Speaker 2: Right.
So then at that point wanted there be like
a surplus to where they could just play, you
know what I mean?
Where it could just be paid for to begin with.
At this point in time.
So to find all of his loans overall this year.
Speaker 1: All all you're saying just pay
off the current loans with the interest that
they've already collected over the years.
Correct.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
I mean, that money has been spent, of course.
But the idea of what you're saying is not
crazy, which is a ton of money has already
been made on the interest on these loans.
But what happened to it?
It was spent on other stuff is the answer,
Shelley.
Speaker 2: Right.
Okay.
All right.
Well, thank you very much.
I appreciate the.
Speaker 1: Time.
Appreciate.
And things are okay in Indiana.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah, they're really.
Speaker 1: I can't.
Honestly, I can't tell if you're kidding.
Speaker 2: I know right now I'm actually kind
of nervous about shoes.
Yeah, because I mean, it's a red state, so
you know what you should keep in mind?
You can always hope for the best.
Speaker 1: And no doubt you will be voting,
I'm sure.
Speaker 2: Oh, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Speaker 1: All right.
Shelly, always great to hear from you.
Thank you.
Speaker 2: All right.
Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
There goes Shelly, an Indiana voting.
That's what you call a likely voter.
She's she's going to vote.
I could just tell she's going to vote.
You can count on Shelly's vote.
That does it for calls today.
We're going to go to a break.
I appreciate every single one of you who has
signed up on the YouTube channel recently.
Approaching 2 million subscribers.
I appreciate everyone who called in.
Even those I did not get to.
But we will take calls again very, very soon